[Music]
so what's the show called what's it
called um
guthur you uh you wanna
tell mr crystal what it's called uh-huh
it's called out of this world
out of this world
that's right just imagine it
ash uh yeah i got it
a spectacular musical that takes your
audience out of this world
i love this song
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
honestly if you could just give me some
dance lessons you would literally be
saving my life wait if you're on a real
show
how come you don't have a choreographer
i do but it turns out it's a massive
weirdo
and how do i know that you're not a
weirdo
how do i know that you're legit would
you come with me to rehearsal see if
you're so whoa whoa whoa i'm not just
gonna follow some guy i don't know to
rehearsal well how else am i supposed to
prove that i'm legit
[Music]
baby there's nothing holding me back
you'll take me places the time my
reputation manipulate my decisions baby
there's nothing holding me back
i knew you were a waiter
[Music]
hold still what are you doing in there
it goes off
crystal got mad and tried to kill me
what
i thought you were stuck come here to
finish me off
[Music]
i know
it's
them pretend we're not here
the first time i'll leave home in 15
years and what do i find
the show's off and this guy's hiding in
the suitcase
[Music]
[Music]
i remember you
we we cannot let that that that bully
steal our hopes and dreams no no no we
are way past singing and dancing now
look i i know this might sound crazy if
we got the theater back
one night seriously it's not like we can
just sneak in there and put the show on
behind crystal's back
that is exactly what we're gonna do
yes
[Music]
maybe it's like room service
open up for your dead moon okay it's not
home service you and your dumb friends
better not be hiding in there what are
we gonna do guys we just gotta be brave
now are you saying we should fight these
thugs no no they'll beat us to a pulp
we're gonna put this show on whether
crystal likes it or not but first
we're gonna jump out that window
what
i'm beginning to like this guy
that volcano should have been finished
yesterday we're on it miss crawley go
baby
darius thank you [ __ ] this time
i'm trying my best miss crawley
a little juice
hey everybody
[Music]
you're two hours late for a rehearsal
wait
where's the koala who are you i'm in
charge you have to then get your tail of
wardrobe sweetheart
mina come and meet your partner oh my
gosh he's here yep he's called darius
won a ton of awards and i think you guys
are gonna have great chemistry you'll
never be alone
i can be a gentleman
anything you want wow that's really
great darius oh yeah it's a scene from
the last jaws and i'm sure you heard of
it hope against hope
gosh i won every award in town i had the
golden piccolo for best crying uh the
archer newman award for outstanding air
oh yeah yeah yeah anyway my co-star she
was just like you gina she was it's mina
excuse me
my name it's mina not gina yeah okay
in the future if you could not interrupt
me that would be way better okay okay
let's rehearse oh can i try no no no no
no i can't let you jump off here daddy
he won't let me jump moon come on let
her do the thing yay where's your weight
[Music]
all right let's get you down rosita oh
my gosh you guys this is exactly like
the dream i had last night
seriously you you were all there and you
and you and that funny-looking guy over
there
all of you
and you asked me to sing for you
i
i did yeah and so i was
like this girl is
[Music]
[Music]
well that's a
lovely dream you had there portia
playback
guys this is the entertainment capital
of the world
i'll give you three weeks to get this
show up and running
johnny you're gonna be working with the
number one choreographer in red shore
city yuck that is rubbish so bad wow
he's freaking me out
i don't see your temper
i'm really having second thoughts about
this
[Music]
i can't do this can i try
[Music]
you're terrific but can she act
take that you nasty alien monster
did i do good oh boy
you have no idea what you're getting
into
whatever podunk town they crawled out of
that's where they belong
cannot let that bully steal our hopes
and dreams guts
faith these are the things you need now
good evening it is my pleasure to
present to you a brand new show
featuring the return of clay halloway
halloween
so step right up and take your seat
[Music]
the journey of a lifetime is about to
[Music]
begin i don't suppose any of you can tap
dance huh
[Music]
okay guys just like we rehearsed
playback
sing two
is incredibly positive so much fun
celebratory i'm telling you it's a smash
it's like being at a rock concert i
think i saw you
it's about music it's about joy
friendship it's literally my dream come
true good evening my name is buster moon
and it is my pleasure to present to you
a brand new show
welcome back mr moon sir we're getting
the gang back together okay this is
great news ah big time baby
the dreams are bigger the stakes are
higher dream big trees that's what i
always said right this is exactly the
kind of big idea i'm talking about
typicals i don't see your tippy toes
it's such an incredible cast already and
then you add in bono pharrell and palsy
like what in the world
[Music]
sing two is that perfect trifecta big
laughs big feelings big songs
time to show the world what we're made
of
it's time for people to come together
and feel just joy
we need some good news we need a fairy
tale to believe in
so sing out loud and dance in the aisles
i want to watch it a thousand more times
i think it's something even buster moon
would be proud of
this is gonna be the greatest show ever
made
[Applause]
just imagine it a spectacular musical
okay everybody lots of energy now and
hello my name is garth jennings and i'm
the writer and director of sing sorry my
dog wants to say hello this is luna
anyway i'm going to take you to the
office with me right now and show you
something i've not shown anyone before
which is how i make the movies
as you can see it's in paris that's the
eiffel tower over there hiding behind
that tree and all the animation is done
here so this is my office and this over
here is my voice booth and record what
we call scratch they're just rough
voices they're not the real voices
they'll be done by the proper actors
once i've got it working but first let's
have a go at some scratch now there's
one voice that i was doing for scratch
that actually ended up being a real
character lap saying sushang courtesy of
mr
[Music]
and that was miss crawling rise and
shine sweetheart here at the studio we
record all the voices for the movie and
we put them all together with the
storyboards and we cut a version of the
movie hi christian i'm not so good in
small spaces and now we need to record
the real actors to bring the characters
to life properly mr moon i'm not so good
in small spaces okay okay somebody's
stuck on my truck okay come on let's get
you out of here
mina do you think that's kind of your
size now all our actors are super
talented i am gonna win a ton of awards
for this my job is to make sure that the
actor is clear on what they're doing and
they feel comfortable to just try
different things out
that's actually quite funny we could use
that for buster so we did we put it in
the movie hey this guy doesn't have it
figured out so we can't start work right
now i have to be open and read the actor
and try and get the best out of them
that also serves my film if you do it
right it can be the most exciting
process in the world yeah i think we
pretty much nailed it there's nothing
holding me back
so there's some examples of what it's
like to direct animation i'll be
finished on scene 2 very soon when it
comes out i really hope you enjoy it
[Music]
bye